the Joe Rogan experience did you know
what that came from do you know what
that's from hookworm hookworm yeah it's
really crazy the the stereotype of the
lazy mouth-breathing southerner came
from massive amounts of people that were
infected with parasites and these
parasites are extremely common
particularly when people walk around
barefoot and they would get these worms
and these worms would get into their
system and one of the side effects of
these worms was a decreased brain
function so that's a that's a real
stereotype that came from a real thing
so huh yeah pull up a hookworm in the
south and then stereotypes because yeah
I forget who told me this then I wound
up going on a deep dive one night and
just reading article upon an article
about this where they didn't even find
out that this was a thing so I think it
was like the 1960s they found out about
this hookworm parasite and this parasite
that was extremely prevalent in the
southeast thing as many of like how
hookworm gave the south a bad name hook
worms once sapped the American south of
its health yet few realize they continue
to affect millions so this is uh that
this worm would infect people that make
that a large place for more than three
centuries a plague of unshakeable
lethargy blanketed the American South it
began with ground itch in in quotes a
prickly tingling in the tender webs
between the toes which was soon followed
by a dry cough weeks later victims
succumbed to an insatiable exhaustion
and an impenetrable haziness of the mind
that some called stupidity adults
neglected their fields and children grew
pale and listless victims developed
grossly distended bellies and angel
wings emaciated shoulder blades
accentuated by the hunching all gazed
out dully from sunken sockets with a
tail tail fish eyes stare the culprit
behind the germ of laziness as
Souths affliction was sometimes called
was nectar americanus the American
murderer better known today as the
hookworm millions of these blood sucking
parasites lived parasites lived fed
multiplied and died within the guts of
up to 40% of the population stretching
from southeastern Texas to West Virginia
hookworm stymied development throughout
the region and bred stereotypes about
lazy moronic southerners that's why you
do it that's why we all do it we do it
because it was a real thing and it was a
real thing because this poor people were
sick with parasites wow wow wow wow I
learned some [ __ ] today Joe and then a
nutty one that's not from Texas that's
when do you go oh okay well that [ __ ]
that makes sense I always used to think
was just hot there and it's hard to
think like you know well now when people
say you don't sound like you're from
Texas I'm like thank you there's a touch
I say y'all still there's a touch to
touch you know no you didn't know that
there was no touch yeah yeah yeah no
yeah you have a touch of sir okay
southern some text in there just a touch
yeah but you definitely not from New
York no I mean from Boston it's like you
have something something going on there
[Applause]